[Inaudible].
Well, it's popping. So today we are going to talk about internships. Yes.
We talk about this all the time, but I love playing him on it.
So today we are going to talk about what are the top 10 software engineering
internships you can get. Now, top internship is really subjective. You know,
some people like, for example, Apple over Google,
some people like Google over Apple,
so you don't really know it's kind of subjective.
And also there's a lot of things to consider like salary, uh, benefits, uh,
prestige, you know,
some people it's all about the respect your parent is all about and then how
much you'll learn.
And then also the team and also the technology that they use.
Some people care about that. Some people don't. So, you know,
so it's kind of hard to consolidate all these together and come up with good
answer until now.
So there's this guy in Waterloo that scraped LinkedIn, you know,
scraped the whole website, looked at all. You want to lose students.
And basically what he did is he looks at every single student and their history
of internships that he did now, Waterloo makes you do six internships.
So basically he made an assumption that your last internship
is better than your before last internship. So for example,
if their first internship was Google and then their next internship was Apple,
he would deem Apple better than Google. Now that's just one person.
So he did that with everyone. You know,
he did that with every single year Waterloo kid and basically gave an ELO score
to every one of these companies.
So now I'm just going to use this website and I'm going to sort it by designable
score. Before I go into the top town,
let me just show you what this site is all about. Uh, this,
I think the site is kind of down now and I kind of just kept a copy for myself.
So, so here's what it looks like. As you can see, every row is a person.
So if you search Citadel, uh, you know,
you see that this guy went to ClearBridge associate,
then TD securities then Citadel.
So that means to do that would be better than all of these companies.
And in code connect would be better than Citadel. Oh, that's me.
That's actually me. I guess that data wasn't very, um, updated.
I can clearly say that Citadel is better than Scotiabank by far
anyway. So this is what it looks like. And then when you aggregate all of this,
you get this with ELO. Uh, I don't know why we can't sort,
I mean, usually you can sort by,
I think it's because the person then they probably didn't do the department.
Didn't scrape the JavaScript. So I have like an old version.
So what we're going to do is we're just going to copy all of that.
And like, as a true data scientist, I'm just going to use Excel. You know,
I was thinking like maybe parsing it or something, but screw that.
I'm just going to use Excel because it seems like it's well formatted.
So all right. Company name, copy, open up Excel.
And uh, okay, cool. And then put a filter here,
filter and then sort D sending.
So I'm not going to tell you, which is first yet,
so I'm going to blur it out here.
I'm just going to blurt a top 10 and as you can see, okay.
Maybe I'll start from the bottom, you know, so you guys know spoilers. So,
you know, for example,
EA is ranked number 24 and he got squared number 22 and then Bloomberg
21, you could see it sorted by ELO score. Yeah. And then, okay,
I'm going to blur out the top. Ooh. The top 10 makes a lot of sense. All right,
let's start. Number 10. We have
Microsoft. You still working for Microsoft.
So you still working for Microsoft.
So yeah. Um, Microsoft is still pretty good then, you know, as not bad, uh,
not going to lie. Microsoft is a pretty good company.
It's just that for me or for my, some of my friends,
we just like to joke around that Microsoft is like a company that's like a low
tier company, but it's not. Microsoft is a great company.
The only reason that we do that is because we have to make fun of one company.
And Microsoft is so big such that if I make fun of them,
they wouldn't care because I'm so small. But yeah,
this is great because I'm able to talk about Microsoft. Okay.
So Microsoft is known to have pretty easy interviews.
I have done their interview for software engineering and for program
manager.
And I would like to say that their software engineering interview was pretty
easy. I pass in one shot.
So the software engineering interview is quite simple for me.
At least they came to Waterloo and I had two interviews back to back.
And then after those two interviews, they'll say you get the internship or not.
So the first question I got was a little bit of a design question with like
databases or like infrastructure. Basically what they're saying is that,
you know,
if you send a certain message to a certain server and they have to send it back
and stuff like that, but what if, if like those messages get lost,
what would you do for fault tolerance and stuff like that?
So a little bit of a design question.
And then the second question is super easy link list. Question is stuff like,
uh, can you find out if the link list has a loop or something like that,
and that is there another way you can do it. I'm not going to go over details,
but basically it's two questions. All right.
Second thing I want to talk about is the salary. Um, for me,
I think the salary for me was like $7,000 a month.
And then you get sick housing. Uh, actually housing is kind of a gamble.
Sometimes you might get better housing sometimes not because they just put
interns everywhere. For me, I was able to go into like a hotel.
I think it was like the Hyatt hotel. And it was pretty dope.
Cause you got made service every single day. So yes,
the benefits were pretty good. All right.
Let me double check the salary real quick, Microsoft. Yeah.
So Microsoft has $7,200 per month,
and then they give you 1,300 for housing or you choose their corporate housing,
obviously choose a corporate housing cause it's way better, but a yeah, 7,200.
This that that's not bad. That's not bad. Um, yeah, I'll show you at the end,
the list, like the salary list and later on, but I don't want to,
you gotta stay through this whole video, just check it out. All right, cool.
Onto the next one on the list. Number nine, it is Yelp.
I had an interview of Yelp for software engineering and their interview.
I would rate it a bit harder than Microsoft. You know, I pass in one shot too,
but they had a lot of interviews. Okay. I think onsite,
I had two onsite interviews and then two full interviews later to confirm
that I wasn't, you know, just lucky and very standard interview questions.
And then, uh, they also look at your projects a little bit.
So I think what I showed them is I showed down a project that you could sync
watching YouTube together. They were pretty impressed by that.
And then a lot of like normal questions,
normal like algorithm questions that you would get on Nico.
So then the phone screen is also just coding. You know that you go on code pad,
they asked you a question and then you code it.
So I think their interview process is a little bit harder and they don't accept
like that many people. All right, let's talk about the salary.
So Yelp is $7,600 per month,
plus $1,500 for housing. If you don't do corporate housing, that is pretty good.
I think Yelp is your position.
You hired them like Google and Microsoft because they're a little bit smaller.
So they have to stay competitive by giving you more money. So yeah.
So salary is pretty good. And then prestige. Um, yeah,
I think Yelp is pretty much mid tier, like, okay, honestly, don't,
don't take my words for granted,
but I'm just like comparing to all the next ones that we're going to see.
But Yelp Yelp is like not like super high tier,
but it's also not like super low tier. It's kind of like with Microsoft,
same level as Microsoft in terms of like prestige in terms of how much you're
going to get next company is Pinterest. Uh,
to be honest, I don't know why this isn't higher. Uh,
it might be just variants to be honest because there aren't that many people
that got into Pinterest because the total number of students that got there,
or like at least scraped it, it was only seven. I do think that, uh,
Pinterest is pretty high up there cause um, I heard from a lot of people, uh,
Pinterest is like one of the smartest companies.
Like every time you go to Pinterest, people say like,
well I've worked with like the smartest people. So yeah,
I think Pinterest should be a little bit higher up. It might be just parents,
like I said. Um, okay. Let's check Pinterest. Ooh.
So how hard is the interview? Uh, I don't know.
I actually don't have a cause I've never interviewed with Pinterest,
so I wouldn't know. So I can't tell you that. Okay.
And then how good the salary is. Alright, you ready?
The salary is $9,000 a month and then
$3,000 for housing.
So that makes it like $12,000 a month. Isn't that crazy?
So yeah, so definitely because of the salary,
people do want to work at Pinterest. Right?
Next company I have here in fusion. Hm.
I'm actually not familiar with this company. Let me Google it real quick.
Or maybe it is a really good company. I don't know, but I don't have, I mean,
if you guys know, please comment below if you know,
infusion and what their reputation is,
but I don't quite know because there's a lot of,
there's a lot of other good companies that didn't make the list. Uh,
I'll give you some spoilers. Amazon did not make the top 10.
LinkedIn did not make the top 10 square did not make the top 10,
but they're all super good companies. It's possible that a lot of smart people,
they got into these companies and then did you scum board?
So they want to work for startups and then it will decrease their yellow.
That's just how it works. But yeah. All right. Company number six. Ooh.
Speaking of Amazon,
I wonder if you can guess which one does is so company number six,
it is a nine.com. So in case you guys don't know what a nine.com is,
subsidiary of Amazon a nine. I think it's more of like the research focus part,
the more data driven part.
So I think they do like a lot of the search functionality of Amazon
and all the hard stuff, the hard problems.
So I had an interview of a nine actually twice actually,
and I got rejected twice. So the first time, um,
yeah, I'm not going to lie. I think it was pretty hard. Um,
I don't remember what the question was,
but I think it was related to dynamic programming and I think it took me some
time to write it and then they also have like a design question. Uh,
I think it's like something related to like either horizontally scaling or very
creased scaling. I think it was like a distributed question,
but basically I didn't do so well.
And then the second time I got the same interviewer and I think I did well
because like, it was the same question, but they still didn't take me.
So I think it's because I was being a Dick. I was like, yeah,
I was there before. Yeah. Whatever, you know, I think,
I think they just didn't like me. So, so how good is the salary?
Let me check. Oh, well then again, I wouldn't know, cause I didn't get the job,
so, but let's look at Amazon.
So Amazon gives you $7,600 a month and
$2,500. So that's pretty average. So I guess it's average,
average salary. I don't think it would be much different from Amazon.
So I think that's,
that's a good estimate of what 89 interns would get 7,600.
Okay. And then in terms of prestige,
it's kind of similar to like it's like Yelp and it's like above Yelp and
Microsoft definitely, definitely below Pinterest.
So I think that's the prestige level, especially in Waterloo.
Like it's pretty good, but it's not like, Whoa, Oh, number five,
Google classic, Google. I mean,
everyone loves so work at Google.
A lot of like really smart people can get through Google early on,
but they also like to come to Google at the end because the company is so big.
You can choose which team to go in.
Some people like to work for this very specific team at Google.
Some people sometimes if you're not like super great at programming or you're
not like a prodigy,
but you can still get to Google because they're so big such that they accept a
lot of interns. So prestige level, I would say pretty high, you know?
Uh, but nowadays it's getting more and more easy to get into Google. And uh,
so I think that's what your values decreasing in terms of like Waterloo
internships. So the interview varies a lot.
So it really depends what your interviewer is.
I personally never gone to Google. Um, I, yeah, I did.
I did a few interviews. I choked,
not a lot of like dynamic programming questions or anything.
Some of them can be simple. I heard some of them can be hard. It really depends.
So a lot of variance there now the salary is pretty,
to be honest. Uh,
I think the reason they can do that is because everyone loves Google.
So they pay you $6,600 per month and then maybe
$3,000 for housing per month. So that makes it maybe 9,600. But yeah,
their base salary isn't that great because it's only 6,600.
So yeah. And then my friends who worked at Google,
they said it was pretty chill. Uh, to be honest, they don't work that hard.
And even once you're full time, uh, if you don't want to,
you could go in teams that don't work really,
really hard and up a Google is really good to work there because later on,
you know, you have a super comfortable life company, number four,
Facebook, Facebook. Oh Facebook. So yeah,
I've never worked as a software engineer at Facebook.
Can I even say that my friends who worked at Facebook said they loved it.
You know, they have a great campus, beautiful campus, uh,
lots of prestige kind of. Yeah. But it's getting bigger.
And once a company gets bigger,
obviously they lose prestige and stuff like that. But, uh, yeah.
So the salary for Facebook interns for software engineering is $8,000
and $1,000 for housing. So in total $9,000,
I'm surprised actually that's quite, that's quite low for housing.
And then Facebook is really good because when you come back as a returning
intern, if you do really well,
you get more stocks and like bonus and stuff like that. So on average,
according to this chart is like $107,000 salary.
You get about $37,500 of stocks per year.
And then your bonus can vary from 75,000 to a hundred thousand dollars
in bonus that that means your first year, you just boom,
a hundred thousand dollars right. In your bank account. So yeah.
So that puts Facebook on number four and then number three.
Is Twitter.
All right. So Twitter is number three.
Twitter is surprisingly not that high in terms of salary.
I'll talk about that later. How hard is the interview?
I remember interviewing for Twitter for software engineering or data science.
I don't remember. And I had a phone screen and with that phone screen I fell.
So I'm guessing Twitter's pretty hard, you know, cause I felt the phone screen,
but, but then again, you know, maybe I just suck. So,
but according to other people, I think Twitter's is also pretty average. Um,
I don't see a lot of people getting into Twitter. So I think Twitter is pretty,
like pretty difficult in terms of like the interview, not super, super hard,
but also not, you know, not super easy, but yeah.
So that's how hard the interview is.
So I can't really tell you anything about that. Uh,
default screen that I had was a dynamic programming question that I screwed up.
How good is the salary? The salary is pretty, actually it's $6,500 per month.
And they give you $2,000 for housing or maybe they have corporate housing.
I'm not sure. Yeah. And then prestige, I think it's,
I think it's pretty up there. Um, I mean,
for some reasons they're losing popularity nowadays.
I mean also this list is kind of old, but yeah, Twitter's losing popularity.
So maybe not that much. All right. Number two.
Okay. So I realize I've been doing this wrong. This should be number one.
So I started number 10, but I realized my Excel sheet. It starts at one,
but then the first row of my cell sheet, it says company name.
So that means I included the Heather, but okay.
So for the number one company I will choose, I would choose one company.
I don't have all of these. And then yeah.
So it's basically gentleman's first company. Alright. Anyways.
So number two company is
Palentier technologies. Oh, I,
I think Palentier is actually the coolest company because I've tried so many
times getting into pond here and I still haven't gotten in yet.
So the first time I had an interview was when I was, uh,
when I was freshman year,
actually I got really lucky because like I talked to this guy and he just gave a
talk about Palentier and he was from Montreal and I was like, Oh, me too.
I'm from Montreal. And then, you know,
he was nice enough to give me an interview. And then I got the phone screen.
The phone screen was actually pretty hard. It was um, well, I don't know,
at least I think it was pretty hard.
It was like print a binary search tree in order or
something like that or like left to right. And that was like, Oh, easy.
I wrote that recursion. And then he's like, all right,
now I'll do it with file recursion. I'm like Nani. And then yeah.
So basically you had to, you know, you,
you just had to make a stack kind of like a, kind of like a recursion stack,
but basically you just have to make a stack. You had to loop it in and Dan,
you pop the stack until there's no more things to pop. Um, you could search,
find a research treat in order to traverse. So, uh,
without recursion and you'll find it. And that's exactly what I did.
So it was a phone screen. Right. And then what I did was, um,
I secretly Googled the answer and went to the week of Peter Page and saw the
pseudo code. And then I just looked at it and said, Oh wait,
I think I understand. And I just wrote the code perfectly for them. Yeah.
So that's that, that's how I got past it.
But then after that I went onsite and then the guy talked to me,
he looked at my resume. He's like, how the did this guy get in?
And then he asked me like a design question and yeah, I,
I just screwed up because I didn't know anything back then. I was just a kid.
So I didn't know anything about different structure.
I only knew about algorithms. So yeah. So I got killed. Hmm. Okay.
It's not that great. So yeah,
the salary is $7,500 per month flat,
that's it? And then you have to pay for your own housing and stuff like that.
So it's not the best. I think this company has a lot of prestige,
especially back then everyone was wearing these like dope pass black sweaters by
Palentier. And everyone felt really cool working. They're not going to lie.
It was a little bit cultish, according to some white friends, but in a good way.
So yeah. And I remember, um, people telling me that their food was amazing.
They have like salmon, you know, like a really nice grilled salmon.
They have like really good chefs to make food. They have massages, you know,
at their campus. So yeah.
So they usually have things like four deployed engineers and normal software
engineers and stuff like that for deployed is pretty cool because it means you
get to travel and you get to, you get to talk with clients and then,
you know, fix their or whatever. But yeah,
it's a really cool company and makes you feel really bad because they're like
gods with data. That's basically what Palentier is. Yeah.
For those who don't know,
Palentier technology is basically like a data consulting company.
Like they don't say they're a consulting company.
They say they're a technology company. But in the end,
I think they're a consulting company.
What'd they do is like they help the government like check out with somewhat bin
Ladin. They help, um, they help like some,
some government stuff to like track down disease and stuff like that.
They probably like do a lot of sketchy stuff that we don't know about because
they're like, there's just really good data.
They help hospitals and stuff like that for,
for processing and analyzing their data. What else? Something more interesting.
Or they help a lot of hedge funds and banks do some financial stuff that we
can't talk about because they're so sick. Good. All right. So number one,
according to my spreadsheet. It's company name. Yeah. All right.
Let me just look at the one that pays the most.
I will say that they're number one. I'm good.
There's a lot. Wait where's Jane street. Oh no, no. Jane Shree is not here.
Wait. Yeah. I don't know. Okay. So Jane street should be here,
but I guess it's not anymore,
but you could kind of know where I'm going with this. Okay. And it was,
I'll just choose this one.
I don't really want to choose it because my brother worked there and I don't
want him to feel proud of him. Oh, okay. it. I'll just choose it. All right.
So the number one company is two Sigma
for you guys who don't know two Sigma is a hedge fund. It's a,
it's a very quantitative based hedge fund.
Meaning they use a lot of tech and to use a lot of numbers to kind of like
decide on what stocks to trade or what commodities to trade and stuff like that.
So they're known to be pretty techie.
They don't like the finance kind of vibe or like finance culture. Uh,
people are not like jocks there. People are like pretty cool. Like basic.
It looks like it looks like a typical tech company when I went there and
visited. So the reason why I chose this,
because the pretty high salary it's $10,400 a month.
And then they give you $5,000 for relocation.
And then they give you $5,000 per month for housing. What the?
Holy. That's crazy. That's more than how much I make as a full-time.
Uh. But yeah. And the bonuses I heard, they're crazy. Like,
why don't you work there? Full-time bonuses are amazing. And uh, yeah,
you wouldn't believe it.
So basically all of these finance companies should be here. Uh,
in case you guys don't know it's not FinTech because FinTech means a technology
company that is about financial products.
Like they help you manage your portfolio, but that's not it,
they use tech so that they can, uh,
so that they can grab a ton of data and then just make a lot of money,
the stock market or whatever that they trade.
So it's totally different than FinTech technologies,
but you can't compare it to like, like Robin hood, you know,
it's not the same thing, but yeah. So two Sigma Citadel Jane street, um, like,
um, Cisco HANA S SIQ notice on Cisco HANA,
uh, Renaissance technology. Actually,
we can't talk about Renaissance technologies because that's just that another
level. So we, that just like, we don't understand what to do, but yeah.
So all of these are really,
really good hedge funds and they probably pay the most compared
to like other tech companies. So, yeah. All right.
So now let me talk about, um, Oh wait, so yeah.
So two Sigma prestige hella. Hi,
it's funny because it wasn't that high before when my brother started,
I remember me telling my friends like, Oh, my brother works at two 78.
They're like, what the is that? I'm like, Oh, it's a finance company. It's like,
Oh, finance is a banker or something like, no,
it's not a banker as a qualitative researcher. But anyways,
two Sigma was not really popular, but nowadays,
because of the emergence of all these finance companies,
and then they realized like, Holy, they pay a lot.
It got the attention of the solver engineers. So, so yeah.
So now prestige definitely high prestige. Uh, people love to Sigma.
They think it's, they think is like the best thing since sliced bread. So yeah.
Pretty good. Alright.
And interview is probably super hard if it's the same or if it's similar to the
full-time interview, a lot of probably questions,
a lot of quantitative questions, a lot of statistics questions,
a lot of brain teasers, lots of hearts. Yes. Questions. I mean, I don't know.
I never got an interview from them, so I wouldn't know. But yeah,
that's what I heard. Um,
there were a lot of companies that did not make the top 10 list.
Don't know why probably because we just don't have that much data. Um,
like I said, this, this set is not super,
super good because it's still kind of hacky,
but let me tell you a few companies that I think deserves, you know,
to share the number one spot. One of them is Snapchat. Of course, come on.
Snapchat is great. Snapchat, such a great company. It's also an LA.
So that's pretty dope. They have a New York office too.
They paid $10,000 a month. So I think Snapchat is really good.
Cora Cora is extremely hard to get in really smart people.
They pay $8,300 a month and then let's see Twitch.
Twitch is super fun. You know,
you get to get to watch people play games all day,
and then they pay you $7,400 a month.
And then Airbnb, Airbnb is really good too.
They pay $7,000 a month plus corporate housing and they give you some Airbnb
credit. Super cool entered. Dog-friendly uh, one of my friends,
yeah. One of my friends interned there and he got to bring his dog every day.
Let's see. Oh, Stripe is really good. Stripe is a really good $7,000 a month.
Plus corporate housing. Definitely good company. It's about payments.
Let's see, Dropbox. Of course, Dropbox is really good.
I'm surprised they're their salary solo $6,300 per month
plus $5,000 housing. Oh,
I guess the $5,000 housing is pretty good or corporate housing,
but I don't think any corporate housing would be $5,000. Maybe that's total.
I'm not sure. So yeah. Yeah. That's pretty much it.
I think these companies are definitely really, really good.
So if ever you have the opportunities to, to work there, definitely do it.
And yeah, if ever you guys are, you know,
inundated by offers from all these companies and you find it really,
really hard to choose, well,
I'm going to link you guys the salary for all of these internships and
also the site that gives you like the ELO and then you could kind of compare and
see which one's better than which well, so yeah,
I hope that was interesting for you guys.
I hope that was useful and a happy job hunting does.
Remember if you enjoyed this video,
don't forget to like and subscribe and then also follow me on Instagram at Joe
Milpa or any other social media site, you know, whatever anyways,
peace out and see you tomorrow. No,
you're probably not going to see him tomorrow.
Not going to make a video tomorrow.